hello word I want to go to the very
basics I want to talk about logging and
monitoring using cloud watch so I want
to start from the very start asking the
question what is cloud watch Klarich is
the monitoring service from AWS it helps
you to keep your logs track some metrics
trigger some alarms it can also record
all the different changes in your
infrastructure so you can do things with
it like to Columbus if you have too many
instances running or things like that it
does all kind of very interesting things
so it's more than just a login tool
so cloud would help you to bring the
visibility from your infrastructure into
one place but I think that's one of the
biggest challenges in areas to see what
is going on in all these different
services and cloud is that place where
you can connect everything together
we have been using cloud watts to check
the logs from lambda's but you can also
do other things we did like check
different metrics in your Dynamo or even
check the logs from the API gateway if
you enable all resources will push some
kind of information to cloud works but
specifically for lambda cloud which is a
great thing because when you have this
execution times that is very limited and
ephemeral and you want to respond as
fast as possible you want that your
login is not consuming thing kind of
your execution time and when you're
working with lambda and cloud watch
lambda will be kind of streaming a
synchronously the logs to cloud watch
and it doesn't consume any extra
execution time in your function and it
doesn't generate any performance issue
as with other libraries external
libraries from AWS that might generate
some problems so that's why usually it's
a good practice to use your cloud watch
vlogging in lambda and then maybe use
some external library to see these logs
or filter these logs or something like
that but but keep the cloud watch as the
log in place for your lambda so now I
want to show you basics of cloud watch
let's go to
try out the metrics the login and the
dashboards and let's go to the console
to get that done let's start by creating
a new empty project this is going to be
a very very very simple project so just
follow the steps as always to create a
simple project with AWS nodejs
as the template we are going to get into
atom and do some small modifications the
code is available on github but this is
very simple code so I just remove all
these comments to make it simpler to
read and then I will create a trigger
for the hello function so we can trigger
this easily what we are going to do here
after we create a trigger is to do a
console log because that's what we want
to try I will just change the message to
something in this console log will just
write hello in the console hello was
called so very simple method so we will
deploy now and we will see what happens
so our speed up the deployment and when
we finish deployment I wish as trigger
this function with that we're elf much a
straight from post one so and we can see
the message so now we can go to lambda
in our account in AWS in the console and
then if you go there and you look for
the function that you just deployed your
watch step hello you can go to
monitoring and there you can see the
different metrics for this function and
you see the logs you can just go to
looks this is one way to find logs and
there you can see the logs for this call
and you can see hello was cold and our
way is a little bit more straightforward
but in a way not that easy sometimes to
find is to go directly to cloud watch
and then go to log and there look for
the logs in the list of lambdas if you
have few lambdas then it becomes very
easy if you have a lot like me this
becomes very painful so when you find
your your lambda then you can get into
the log group
and then you can see exactly the same
another way to do that to see the logs
my favorite I will say is to see the
logs from the surrealist framework in
your terminals so you just type a
Celeste logs - eff the name of the
function and - tip to tail the log so
this if you keep on calling it will keep
on appearing if you don't put the minus
T it was just print whatever is there
another thing you can do with cloud
watch as I said is to create dashboards
with metrics so I will just create a new
dashboard and put name testing cloud
watch you can put any name you want and
there you have an empty dashboard and
there you can add widgets these
dashboards you can display in a screen
or you can have them open to see how
your service is performing and when you
are a new metric you can look for the
different services so we will just look
for lambda and then you can look by
function name and there is all the
functions there then I will just look
for the cerullo's cloud watch and you
can search so it becomes easier if you
put the name of the function it just
shows that it filters out the rest and
then if you see on the right you will
start seeing some dots appearing those
are like the only time we invoke this
function so there's only one but if this
is called many times then you will see
lines so you can define things like the
order in which these metrics are shown
you can also define the period that
these metrics are showing so either one
second of information or five minutes or
one hour and depending on that you are
going to see different things the period
and the statistics will make you see
different things so it's important when
you tune your dashboard to something
that you understand
so if I put 30 seconds the average it
will be the range in 30 seconds but I
want the sum in 30 seconds so it's a
different value than the average this
case is the same because I only call it
once but if you have multiple for some
metrics the average is good for others
to some is better and then you have some
graph options you can put
tations you can define what kind of data
you how you want to show the data and
that's kind of the graph then you can
add numbers those graphs that's
something I like
some things are easy to see as a number
so let's just look again for the for the
same function and then you can see if I
change the period then the average just
disappears there's not enough data so
now we have it one minute and we don't
have any data there so in order to get
some data what I will do is I will
trigger this function many times so we
can see in one minute I don't know how
many invocations will have this takes a
while usually cloud watch is almost real
time so you need sometimes to wait a
little bit now if i refresh this graph
you can see that there is some values
and we can see that there is some
invocation and also you can see now that
we have called this a couple of times so
if I change the period and I change the
statistic you start seeing things
differently so you have a lot of
implications in one minute
therefore in one hour there's an eight
so it's different different values so
you can play a little bit with that but
always be careful on what is your period
and what is your metric that sometimes
those numbers can be deceiving if you
don't know what you're putting there so
another thing you can do is you can
change the period that you're showing
the data so even if the metric is being
displayed for every 30 seconds you can
also show what has happened in the last
hour in the last three hours in the last
day or then you can show what happened
in the last minute or in the last 15
minutes and thanks for that remember
that you need some data this was the
video for today I hope you liked it if
you did give a big thumbs